[Musique]
soirée de tension place de la république
à paris
les forces de l'ordre ont démantelé sans
ménagement un nouveau campement de
migrants bien la réponse de ce
gouvernement
vous avez vu comme moi c'est la
gendarmerie qui par la force et celle
d'arracher des tentes alors qu'à des
personnes à l'intérieur voilà c'est une
honte
sous les cris de la foule et des
associations présentes la tension monte
très vite un journaliste à terre reçoit
des coups de matraque
[Musique]
dès samedi prochain matin plusieurs
changements seront réalité d'abord les
déplacements pour motif de promenade aux
activités physiques en extérieur seront
désormais permis dans un rayon de 20 km
et pour trois heures tout chaud ça les
six députés méchoui pas qu'ils vont vous
ne sais pas comme ça reculé en sachant
pas si ça va maintenant ça commence à
aller ça supportable
eric coquerel kaki content d'aller
affronter assez preuve d'assez près les
les
les policiers donc on peut se poser la
question de leur volonté du message à
faire passer et des images que ça va
véhiculer parce qu'il savait très bien
que la police quoi qu'il arrive
utiliserait un peu la force
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenus
très vite et très fort à tel point que
gérald darmanin parle d' images
choquantes et exige un rapport avant
midi vous comprenez la réaction du
ministre de l'intérieur non j'avoue je
ne la comprends pas et je la trouve
assez lâches
ce rapport n'a été hormis est donc celui
ci m'a proposé la saisine de l'igpn sur
plusieurs faits inacceptables j'ai
demandé donc à l'igpn la police des
polices de remettre ses conclusions sous
48 heures hélas le ministre leur tombe
dessus ce matin j'avoue ne pas
comprendre ces hésitations permanente
c'est ses ordres ses comptes d'ordre
c'est inacceptable la façon dont ils
sont traités
ça demande quand même que le préfet en
rendre compte et en rendre compte ce
n'est pas la première fois quand même
venant du préfet de police de paris est
un problème avec digital il a comme
instruction de ne laisser aucune
implantation de camp de migrants à paris
en cela il n'est pas aidé par la mairie
de paris puisque elle n'adhère pas aux
dispositifs nationaux et d'autre part il
n'est pas aidé puisqu'il il met en
première ligne nos forces de l'ordre la
police nationale parce que madame
hidalgo reflux est ce qu est le
responsable en première ligne c'est le
préfet et je vais vous dire très
clairement ce matin je demande la
démission du préfet monsieur didier
lallement
ça suffit à cause de ce qui s'est passé
un autre nom c'est une accumulation il
n'a pas en complément et en soutien une
police municipale armée qui pourrait
aider ces formations la police à me
laisser des élus dont j'étais juste pour
nous empêcher de protéger ces gens
la police a frappé des journalistes
juste pour les empêcher de dire la
vérité
cela fait deux ans que les mouvements
sociaux sont confrontés à une doctrine
qui ne vise plus à maintenir la paix
mais à maintenir l'ordre
votre ordre injuste je crois aussi qu'il
ya beaucoup d' instrumentalisation
retour de ces affaires et moi ce que je
trouve le plus choquant c'est
d'instrumentaliser la situation de
personnes en grande difficulté à des
fins politiciennes
tous les commerces pourront rouvrir et
les services à domicile reprendre mais
dans le cadre d'un protocole sanitaires
strictes
j'ai constaté notamment parce que je
suis intervenu publiquement que monsieur
procure la république de paris a ouvert
une enquête sur une un des faits qui a
été évoqué personnellement je m'en
réjouis la justice fera son travail
quartier de la petite hollande à
montbéliard mon choix
c'est bien d'abord d'une pelleteuse
volet de 6 tonnes que des individus s'en
prennent à des mâts de vidéosurveillance
se poser à cet engin roulant de 6 tonnes
or nous aurait mis en situation d'usagé
des armes ce qui était totalement
impensable et non souhaitable si nous
sommes bien arrivés autour des 5000
contamination par jour et environ 2500 à
3000 personnes en réanimation
nous pourrons alors franchir un nouveau
cap
alors le confinement pourra être levée